hi there today uh i'm going to show you
four minutes of me struggling with my
dry cleaner
um
more or less communicating
and then another four minutes of a
little bowl session that we had in the
office where we talk about what can be
achieved in three months so
i hope this is um useful to you um
you know my feeling is that
i'm certainly not
frustrated or disappointed but i'm
reminded that it takes a long time to
learn a language it takes a long time
for the brain to get used to it but it
eventually does
and so one just has to continue that's
basically you got to stay the course
that's what it comes down to so um look
forward to your comments
um
um
if you
uh
um
um
foreign
but you know what three months is not an
awful lot of time
you know i'm beginning to doubt as just
how much am i going to achieve
i'm going to put up my video of visiting
the dry cleaner
i understood what i was saying
i didn't understand much of what they
were saying
and and i was thinking you know
with russian czech as well i mean it
just takes a long time takes a long time
to get to the point where you can
actually understand what people are
saying
but you always talk about you sort of
have your good days and your bad days
and some days you think you're not
making progress and then all of a sudden
you discover hey i understood that and
so maybe that's going to be
well you know and there are days if
anything my speaking is improving faster
than my comprehension
and i'll be in conversations where as
long as they're talking about a subject
about can understand you know i can
participate and and in fact i give them
the impression that i'm quite good
and that encourages them
and then i'm lost
but it also depends on the subject yeah
but i'm still curious to see my biggest
thing is how much can my comprehension
improve between now and basically the
15th of april
comprehension is the big one yeah and i
was also commenting that uh when i
listened to
sons stuff anything that's kind of
sheltered they speak more slowly and
pronounce clearly i say wow i understand
and then when you get to the real thing
real people talking it's just a totally
different uh
yeah that's how it starts i mean that's
why people speak to their kids slowly
and i mean you just have to get it
first slowly i think and then over time
you get used to quickly and deciphering
what people are saying but i think you
have to listen to people speaking
quickly because kids while the parents
might speak slowly to the kid the kid is
listening all the time to people
speaking at normal speed right and if
the kid doesn't hear people speaking at
normal speed he wouldn't progress so i'm
certainly pushing myself to stay with
the the normal speed korean i'm just not
gonna occasionally
you know if i'm doing something where
i'm concentrating on something else
where otherwise it's just noise in the
background then i'll put something
easier on but other than that in my
listening i try to listen to more
challenges and you were saying before
how uh people a lot of times want to
stay with the beginner stuff because
they do understand it and it makes them
feel comfortable but you were saying
that actually you have to start
listening to the hard stuff the stuff
that you can't decipher in order to
start to be able to decipher well i i
think so i mean i haven't don't have any
scientific facts but i think you
you uh i like to mix it because
otherwise it can be frustrating to
constantly be listening to stuff that
you don't understand
but i think in terms of the brain
getting used to it you know you're
picking words out here and there
certainly now when i listen to korean
spoken at normal speed i hear every word
okay which i didn't before before it was
more indiscriminate noise now i hear
every word but but i don't know what the
word means or i may know the odd word
but i can't put meaning to the whole
thing but so there is a progression
there
so we just have to and there was in fact
there was a question on our forum
someone said how difficult is it to
understand movies it's very difficult
galena you speak excellent english what
you do
when when you listen to a movie
do you understand everything
i think i understand maybe
92. oh that's 95 but maybe some slang
some expressions right oh but that's
very good
i must say i lived in japan for nine
years
for the first five years i couldn't
understand other soap operas how much of
that did you watch
not an awful lot so maybe that's why
partly i didn't i don't know the context
so you have to know the context i
understood the baseball games that was
the first thing i could understand
i actually was watching a
korean movie earlier this week and uh
it was like
the movie was like gangsters and they're
fighting and like all this kind of stuff
like i don't know any of that stuff so
i'm watching i'm like man like i've been
studying korean for like six and a half
years i'm watching this movie and i'm
understanding like 50
almost like all going over my head i'm
like this is really
quite quite depressing at this point but
i guess it's the thing too like i'm not
exposed to that kind of language you
know i didn't grow up in korea in high
school
with other friends talking and slang and
stuff so
i can't really expect that it's just
gonna go there right i mean this is the
thing i always say like you will never
have the same range of knowledge
vocabulary that a local has
so you don't need the gangster
vocabulary so it doesn't matter that's
the way i look at it well if you want to
watch it depends what you want to get
you know if you want to watch gangster
movies and you like that kind of thing
then then it's good but you'll learn the
things
by the by the 20th youngster movie
you'll have a lot of that exactly yeah
yeah anyway i better go home and study
korean
all right okay yeah bye